[Musique]
nous voici à maslovka à cinq heures de
route au sud de moscou c'est ici que
wladimir borov moscovite diplômée de la
sorbonne a décidé de construire une
ferme il y a dix ans et du produire du
fromage selon les traditions françaises
nous allons maintenant le rencontrer
bonjour bonjour merci
[Musique]
comment vous êtes retrouvés à la
sorbonne dû partir à paris pour faire
les études assure bonne en 1981 pendant
trois ans je faisais mes études et mon
stage en france et puis j'ai travaillé
comme journaliste en france plusieurs
années plus de 20 ans veut travailler en
permanence en france je retourner en
russie je travaillais comme journaliste
de cinéma dans tous les festivals
français et puis j'ai décidé de créer ma
ferme ici sauf que lorsque lissiers on
est en plein nature il ya plein des
différents animaux il ya les rivières
qui sont propres il ya l'air qui épure
et il ya les herbes qui sont guéris 100
mg et animaux sont heureux ici sur les
pâturages de maslovka et moi je suis
heureux
[Rires]
si brave racontez nous un peu comment
vous avez appris ses savoir-faire de
fabrication du fromage j'ai invité ici à
maslovka lé célèbre fromager français
avec un gant d'expérience gilles inique
de bouge et le 14 juillet 2015 au jour
de fête nationale de france si l'on
arrivait à maslovka et ils ont fait des
notes directement sur nos murs et donc
ici ils ont marqué tous les éléments de
tous les étapes de production de fromage
donc tout ça ce sont les étapes à
travers lequel il faut passer le fromage
pour qu'il soit très bon à signer est
réellement français ils sont restés deux
mois c'est simple oui ils ont rester ici
deux mois et pendant ces deux mois nous
avons travaillé ensemble
après mois le train et eux seuls ils ont
regardé et fais et leur note
est comme ça après je vais encore plus
quelques stages en france chez eux sur
leur ferme et après j'ai passé des
examens et j'ai reçu le diplôme de
fromager et ont produit les fromages ici
dans cet étage
nous avons pour l'instant très petit
production parce que mettons tous nos
bêtes ils sont enceintes nous avons très
peu de lait est très petite production
de fromage la durée de l'affinage en
perd six mois à un an
est donc ici c'est tout ça ce sont les
fromages de maslovka avec les non
français par exemple des érables devouge
nous ne commercialisons nos faux mal
nulle part sauf maslov câble il y à
beaucoup des gens qui arrivent
directement jusqu à maslovka c'est pas
très loin de moscou c'est 330 km de
moscou il ya beaucoup de deux bus et de
voitures individuelles qui arrivait
frédérice des français il ya les russes
le français il ya déjà beaucoup de gens
qui aiment les fromages français l'écart
malheureusement il n'arrive pas de la
france on le produit sur place ici et
les gens ont l'habitude d'acheter
[Musique]
c'est ici que sa chaîne notre visite de
maslovka ce petit village devenu une
destination très prisée par les nombreux
amateurs de fromage en russie la nature
des animaux du fromage de tradition
française et en plus il est bon